I got off a one-hour meeting with a guy
who's 66 years old he he's talking about
a project that's going to take him 20
years to build in 20 years I'm going to
be 66 like him and then I love to play
this game and 20 years ago I was 26 and
I started playing in that game and I'm
like damn I got so much time I just
really I actually have really begun to
believe that humans poor relationship
with time not actually understanding how
much time they do have is what's [__]
everybody up if 23 year olds knew what
it felt like to be 45.
feel this young they would slow their
[__] down they're so in a rush to show
everybody else that they made it that
they put so much pressure on themselves
for no [__] reason